donc ça normalement c'est ça fait partie
des ce qu'on appelle les housses
plastiques donc c'est pas censé du tout
être au carton voilà une paire de
chaussures ça c'est l'auréole de Jésus
est-ce qu'on appelle de l'osier c'est de
l'OM de l'ordure ménagère c'est
absolument pas recyclable
[Musique]
alors là je suis en crier sur la ligne
des EMR donc c'est emballages ménagers
recyclables donc tout ce qui est petit
cartonné de yaourt
tous les petits cartons qu'on a par
exemple quand on fait les courses les
petites cartonnettes on met dans les
dans les bacs jaunes
exactement on a le métal on a le blé
plastique donc tout ce qui est
bouteilles plastique on a toutes les
balles au carton le papier et voilà tout
ce qui est alu normalement on a que ça
mais parfois ça arrive qu'on retrouve
des choses enfin même beaucoup de choses
qui devront pas arriver ici comme des
animaux
on a retrouvé plusieurs chevreuils on
retrouve des évidemment des rats des
souris j'ai déjà vu aussi des bébés
chiots ça c'était je pense que si tout
le monde sera informé correctement il y
aurait beaucoup moins d'erreurs parce
que des fois quand on parle de bague
entourage je dis oui ça ça va pas
là-dedans c'est bon bah je savais pas
enfin pour nous du moins parce que c'est
nous qui faisons tout le travail
derrière on serait beaucoup plus aidé
oui souvent on est déjà arrivé je me
suis déjà fait piquer il peut y avoir
des seringues
et ça c'est très dangereux pour nous
parce que tout dépend de la densité du
tapis donc on les voit pas forcément
il y a une période où on a trouvé
beaucoup sympa et des personnes qui
savent tout froid que que ça se recycle
et en fin de compte pas du tout semble
qu'on a un objectif quotidien c'est de
trier 50 tonnes de déchets par jour
c'est énorme mais en soi réparti sur
toutes les chaînes et tout au long de la
journée ça va vite aussi
oui c'est déjà dans des machines avant
et nous on affine tout le pliage en fait
ça passe dans une grosse machine qui
s'appelle le traumel là en fait c'est un
calibre les déchets et puis après dans
d'autres machines justement pour affiner
pour que nous ensuite à la fin qu'on
aille vraiment le minimum à faire
tout est stocké et ensuite avec une
presse en fait ils font des des grosses
balles après c'est c'est usine de
recyclage alors avant moi j'étais déjà
dans le déchet j'étais gardien de
déchets j'étais aussi ce qu'on appelle
Reaper à l'arrière des camions j'étais à
l'arrière des camions effectivement
il fallait aussi gérer comment dire le
côté monté sur le marché descendre du
marche-pied gérer les poubelles en bonne
organisation c'est quoi le futur
le plus dur dans ce métier c'est le
cumul de fatigue au bout d'un moment des
fois suivant les les quantités qui
passent sur la chaîne alors il y a des
chaînes un peu plus complexes que
d'autres on va avoir la chaîne ce qu'on
appelle les corps creux au niveau de du
tri des bouteilles des briques de lait
le passage du tapis était très étroit à
la vitesse à laquelle ça va il faut
avoir l'oeil et il faut vraiment comment
dire être au taquet quoi sur le sur tout
ce qui passe quoi
faut que je fasse le calcul non on est
de 7h45 à aller 17h15 avec une pause
d'une heure et demie de midi normalement
on a une journée de 8h donc si on fait 8
x 5 40
donc ouais
au moins au moins 40 heures
oui ouais tous les mêmes gestes ça c'est
répétitif donc les bras les épaules même
les poignées travaillent beaucoup
au début ce que j'avais beaucoup de mal
c'était de rester debout toute la
journée donc faut tenir plus dur ouais
c'est ça on fait toujours les mêmes
gestes donc des fois les douleurs au dos
qui arrivent des douleurs dans les
poignées dans les épaules chaque
personnellement certains sont là par
cette par nécessité plus qu'autre chose
moi je suis aussi là par conviction et
notamment du fait que j'ai travaillé en
déchetterie donc moi j'ai découvert ce
monde là j'ai découvert aussi
l'importance du tri en soi et j'aime me
sentir utile ça me je trouve ça assez
gratifiant d'être un rouage de la chaîne
du de la du tri tout simplement